ja denn bevor sich eine neue regierung
findet muss erstmal diese neunzehnte
legislaturperiode beginnen das wird sie
gleich hier mit der eröffnung durch den
alterspräsidenten nach artikel 39 des
grundgesetzes tritt der bundestag
spätestens am 30 tag nach der wahl
zusammen das wurde auch diesmal wie
schon vor vier jahren voll ausgeschöpft
aber wir haben natürlich einige
besonderheiten ulrich deppendorf über
die wir vorher schon gesprochen haben
die afd
und da hat er bereits der zehnte
deutsche bundestag eine lex afd
geschaffen denn hier eröffnet immer noch
ein sehr alter mensch aber er ist nicht
mehr der an jahren älteste es nicht mehr
den jahren älteste sondern er ist der
dienstälteste das hat man gemacht in der
letzten zeit der letzten
legislaturperiode um nicht in die lage
zu kommen dass der in der älteste
sozusagen der ein abgeordneter der ard
hier der als alterspräsident diese
sitzung eröffnet das wäre von gottlob
gottlob geworden
das hat man dann geändert hat es
diskussionen darüber gegeben müssen wir
das eigentlich machen können wir da
nicht viel lockerer mit umgehen aber die
meinung hat sich durchgesetzt nein das
kann nicht sein dass der ein
rechtsnationaler rechtsradikalen
einschlag einer partei möglicherweise
hier die us präsident
abgibt und dann diese sitzung hier
eröffnet und deswegen die neue regelung
der dienstälteste da sind sie in dem
fall als auch die solms von der fdp
hermann otto solms genauer noch zu solms
ein ganz erfahrener mann mittlerweile
auch in den siebzigern und der hier
schon fraktionsvorsitzender bei der fdp
der minister war der schatzmeister der
fdp war ein urgestein der freien
demokraten der jetzt nachdem er 2013
auch ausscheiden musste bitter für ihn
damals jetzt wieder gewählt worden ist
und heute hier diese sitzung als
alterspräsident dürfen in der sie mir
gar die bundeskanzlerin sie haben ist er
seit 1990 im parlament hermann otto
solms seit 1980 natürlich einen
abgeordneten der ist der allzeit rekord
halter viel viel länger im parlament als
hermann otto solms und da hat man gleich
mit diesem neuen gesetz der nächsten
konflikt geschaffen das ist nämlich
wolfgang schäuble sitzt seit 1972 im
deutschen bundestag unbeschreibliche 45
jahre und nun hat man ihn ausgeguckt
dass der bundestagspräsident wird und 12
ja klar er kann dann hier nicht eröffnen
diese wichtige rede halten denn der
bundes der alterspräsident hält ja
gleich hier die eröffnungsrede
also wolfgang schäuble mit abstand der
älteste ist ja auch derjenige der hier
den laden in den griff kriegen wird ist
ja der richtige richtige wahl
ich glaube ja es die richtige wahl ist
sicherlich der erfahrenste von allen
hier im deutschen bundestag wolfgang
schäuble kann alles kann katz günstig
sein kann
souverän sein
er hat erfahrungen wie man sozusagen mit
großen versammlungen umgeht nicht nur
hier sondern auch international
er ist von allen respektiert manche
kritisieren ihn natürlich auch hart auch
heute morgen doch noch einmal sigmar
gabriel der gesagt hat also wolfgang
schäuble hätte einen scherbenhaufen in
europa hinterlassen von in seiner
finanzpolitik der jetzt auch gelobt hat
und sagt ich werde ihn wählen wird den
laden hier gut im griff geklaut das hat
jetzt auch alles ein bisschen
wahlkampfthema das muss man außerdem
spielt alles eine rolle aber alle
spd/grüne ich habe eigentlich keinen
gefunden der gesagt hat wolfgang
schäuble ist nicht der richtige meinung
jetzt erheben sich die abgeordneten
denn nun beginnt die konstituierende
sitzung des deutschen bundestages
ja und hermann otto solms wie gesagt
wird jetzt hier gleich die sitzung
eröffnen und immerhin man redet ja auch
gerne vom hohen haus ist das hier auch
ein zeichen des respektes hier vor dem
ersten gesetzgebern die ja alle zusammen
hier sind die 709 abgeordneten
hoffentlich verhalten sie sich auch in
dieser legislaturperiode dementsprechend
ganz kurze verein ausrichten darf diese
eröffnungsrede welche funktion hatte ja
das ist vielleicht heute eine ganz
besondere funktion dem hoffentlich lagen
macht und bleibt ruhig auch meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren kollegen
korreliert
es ist ein die neuen sonstiger beheben
sollte hermann otto solms zu bundestages
es entspricht der ständigen übung zu
beginn der konstituierenden sitzung nach
den regelungen der bisherigen
geschäftsordnung des deutschen
bundestages zu verfahren
§ 1 absatz 2 der geschäftsordnung des
deutschen bundestages sieht vor dass das
am längsten dem bundestag angehörende
mitglied das hierzu bereit ist den
vorsitz übernimmt ist der deutsche
bundestag einen präsidenten gewählt hat
die fraktion der afg widerspricht diesen
verfahren und hat auf burg satzvey
beantragt einen versammlungsleiter zu
wählen der die konstituierende sitzung
über diesen antrag lasse ich sofort
abstimmen wer dem antrag der fraktion
der afg zustimmt denn bitte ich um sein
handzeichen dankeschön gegenstimmen
dankeschön
enthaltungen der antrag ist damit mit
den stimmen aller fraktionen bei
zustimmung der fdp fraktion abgelehnt
wir verfahren nunmehr entsprechend § 1
absatz 2 der bisherigen geschäftsordnung
herr dr wolfgang schäuble ist das
mitglied das dem deutschen bundestag am
längsten angehört er hat jedoch auf das
amt des alterspräsidenten verzichtet
damit rückt das am zweitältesten dem
bundestag angehörende mitglied nach ich
war von 1980 bis 2013 also 33 jahre
mitglied des deutschen bundestages ist
jemand unter ihnen der den bundestag
länger angehört
das scheint offenkundig nicht der fall
zu sein
dann trifft es also tatsächlich zu dass
die rolle des alterspräsidenten auf mich
zukommt es ist mir eine ehre und freude
zugleich den vorsitz bis zur
amtsübernahme durch die neu gewählten
präsidenten des deutschen bundestages zu
übernehmen
damit hoffe ich nun den
tagesordnungspunkt 11 auf die eröffnung
der sitzung
ich eröffne als alterspräsident die
erste sitzung des 19
der 19 wahlperiode und begrüße zunächst
den bundespräsidenten herrn dr
frank walter steinmeier wir freuen uns
wir freuen und sehr bundespräsident der
sie unter uns sind und dieser
konstituieren beiwohnen
desweiteren begrüße ich hat sich die
ehemalige präsidentin des deutschen
bundestages vdr rita süßmuth
sowie die ehemaligen präsidenten des
deutschen bundestages herrn dr wolfgang
thierse
und natürlich den hochgeschätzten
kollegen dr norbert lammert der ja dem
bundestag bis heute vergessen
es ist mir ein besonderes anliegen frau
inge deutschkron zu begrüßen die ja im
jahre 2013 eine sehr bewegende rede hier
im deutschen bundestag
aus anlass des holocaust-gedenktages
gehalten hat
mein gruß gilt auch den anwesenden
botschaftern und missionschefs sowie
allen weiteren gästen die auf der
tribüne in dieser sitzung teilnehmen
außerdem
außerdem möchte ich dem kollegen
reinhold sendker zu seinem heutigen 65
geburtstag gratulieren
als nächstes habe ich gemäß § 1 absatz 3
der geschäftsordnung die vorläufigen
schriftführerinnen und schriftführer zu
ernennen
nach absprache mit den fraktionen
benenne ich als vorlage für die
schriftführerinnen und schriftführer die
damen und herren abgeordneten ich
verliere jetzt die liste artur
auernhammer doris barnett heike behrens
dr karamba diaby sabine dittmar
katharina dröge dr fritz felgentreu dr
thomas gebhart christiane haase marina
harder kühnel tschuldigung mariana
harder kühnel sebastian hartmann marc
helwig carsten hilse thomas häßler
dieter jahre jack kerstin kassner von
jack ma jens koeppen markus koob dr
katja leicas alexander müller bettina
müller norbert müller
beate müller gemmeke völker münster
dr alexander neu ulli nissen um die
nouripour friedrich ostendorff tabea
rößner manuel sarrazin bullish aus dr
wieland schinnenburg benjamin strasser
karin werner kathrin werner nicole
vastic peter k wolfgang viele juristen
yüksel hubertus zdebel stefan zierke
pia zimmermann die abgeordneten jens
koeppen und doris barnett bitte ich
neben mir platz zu nehmen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren bitte
haben sie verständnis dass ich meinen
ausführungen eine sehr persönliche
erklärung vorausschicken möchte ich
freue mich ganz außerordentlich dass
gerade ich als mitglied der fraktion der
freien demokraten
die sitzungsperiode des neunzehnten
deutschen bundestags eröffnen darf nach
vier schwierigen jahren in der
außerparlamentarischen opposition haben
wir das vertrauen der wählerinnen und
wähler zurückgewonnen
jetzt können wir der liberalen stimme im
deutschen bundestag wieder gehör
verschaffen und das war unsere zentrale
aufgabe und unser ziel
vielen dank für ihr verständnis meine
damen und herren vorweg möchte ich allen
kolleginnen und kollegen zu ihrer
wiederwahl beziehungsweise neuwahl in
den deutschen bundestag herzlich
gratulieren
abgeordnete des deutschen bundestages zu
sein ist eine große ehre aber eine noch
viel größere verpflichtung dieser müssen
wir alle in den nächsten jahren gerecht
werden
der deutsche bundestag ist das einzige
direkt vom volk legitimierte staatsorgan
er steht damit im mittelpunkt unserer
staatlichen ordnung auf den sich alle
anderen organe beziehen
der deutsche bundestag ist darüber
hinaus eines der einflussreichsten
demokratischen parlament der welt das
wird schon dadurch deutlich dass sich
der bundestag seine regierung wählt
diese beauftragt kontrolliert und gegen
gegebenenfalls wieder ersetzen kann
die regierung ist also immer auf das
vertrauen des bundestages angewiesen
der bundestag wählt seine regierung und
nicht die regierung seien bundestag das
wird in der öffentlichen übertragung
häufig nicht eindeutig dargestellt die
in der verfassung vorgesehene
richtlinienkompetenz des bundeskanzlers
bzw der bundeskanzlerin bezieht sich nur
auf das handeln der regierung und nicht
auf die entscheidungsfindung im
deutschen bundestag auch wenn das in den
medien häufig anders dargestellt wird
der bundestag der bundestag bestimmt die
politischen zielsetzungen und die
grundsätzlichen lösungswege die
regierung führt sie aus an zwei
beispielen möchte ich deutlich machen
wie weit die entscheidungsbefugnisse des
bundestages reichen
zu beginn der neunzigerjahre verklagte
die fdp-bundestagsfraktion die eigene
regierung vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht wegen der
zulässigkeit der out of area einsätze
der bundeswehr als damaliger
fraktionsvorsitzender habe ich die klage
vor dem bundesverfassungsgericht
vertreten genauso wie der bis heute
unvergessene kollege peter struck der
die gleichzeitige klage der damaligen
oppositionsfraktionen spd vertreten hat
aufgrund dieses urteils des
bundesverfassungsgerichts bedürfen
seither alle auslandseinsätze der
bundeswehr der zustimmung des
parlamentes deswegen entsprechend wir ja
heute von einer parlamentsarmee
das ist der zusammenhang eine
verantwortung die in anderen ländern
unbekannt ist häufig auf verwunderung
stößt sich bei uns aber nach meiner
meinung bewährt hat diese regelung
diese regelung die start und soldatinnen
und soldaten vor leichtfertigen
entscheidungen schützt sollte bei einer
einbettung der bundeswehr in europäische
beteiligungsstrukturen grundsätzlich
beibehalten wird auch im rahmen der
euro-stabilisierung haben wir ein
höchstmaß an parlamentarischer kontrolle
erreicht und im september 2011
rechtsgeschichte geschrieben
damals ist es zum ersten mal gelungen
einen flächendeckenden
parlamentsvorbehalt gegenüber den
vorrechten der regierung bei der
außenvertretung des staates zu
installieren
dieser gilt bei allen die
haushaltsverantwortung des bundestages
betreffenden entscheidungen der
bundesregierung zur euro-stabilisierung
wir haben dieses königs rechts des
parlaments nämlich das haushaltsrecht in
gesetze gegossen welche dieses recht
garantieren
das recht des parlamentes über die
einnahmen und ausgaben des staates zu
bestimmen darf auch in zukunft nicht
eingeschränkt werden
in dieser auffassung hat uns damals das
bundesverfassungsgericht bestärkt ich
zitiere für die einhaltung des
demokratie gebots kommt es vielmehr
entscheidend darauf an dass sie das der
deutsche bundestag der ort bleibt an dem
eigenverantwortlich über einnahmen und
ausgaben entschieden wird auch im
hinblick auf internationale und
europäische verbindlichkeiten ende des
zitats liebe kolleginnen kollegen das
wahlergebnis vom 24 september hat die
kräfteverhältnisse im 19ten deutschen
bundestag stärker verändert als
gemeinhin erwartet wurde und gleich auch
die politischen rollen neu verteilt
diese entscheidung der wähler haben wir
zu akzeptieren
das parlament
das parlament muss ein spiegelbild der
meinungsvielfalt in der bevölkerung sein
ich warne davor sonder regelungen zu
schaffen auszugrenzen oder gar zu
stigmatisieren
wir alle haben das gleiche man da
wir alle haben das gleiche mandat
gleiche rechte aber eben auch gleiche
pflichten
es ist klug sich im politischen
wettbewerb auf inhaltliche
auseinandersetzung zu konzentrieren
dabei gilt jeder der hier das wort
ergreift übernimmt persönlich die
verantwortung für das gesagte durch die
wahl sind wir jetzt die repräsentanten
des volkes und der wille des volkes von
dem jahr alle staatsgewalt ausgeht ist
maßstab unseres handelns
selbstverständlich fühlen wir uns alle
auch verantwortlich gegenüber unseren
parteien die uns als kandidatin
nominiert haben und das grundgesetz
bestimmt dass die parteien bei der
politischen willensbildung mitwirken
ohne parteien ist dies auch gar nicht zu
organisieren
wer demokratie bejaht muss auch
demokratische parteien bejahen
es ist zu bedauern wie wenig die
mitgliedschaft inter oder die
unterstützung demokratischer parteien in
der öffentlichkeit gewürdigt wird
wie wird dürfen die ehrenamtliche und
unentgeltliche arbeit von 10.000 von
politikern gerade auf kommunaler und
regionaler ebene nicht vergessen ohne
die demokratische willensbildung
überhaupt nicht möglich wäre
deshalb danke ich heute besonders allen
die bei der bundestagswahl bei landtags
oder kommunalwahlen kandidiert aber eben
kein mandat erhalten haben
sie haben mit ihrem engagement einen
besonderen beitrag für die lebendige
demokratie geleistet
parteien stehen das politische personal
die kandidaten für politische ämter und
nehmen zusätzlich einfluss auf die
rekrutierung und die besetzung von
leitenden positionen in verwaltung und
gerichten
das ist viel macht die große
verantwortung mit sich bringt und ein
hohes maß an selbstkontrolle und selbst
sieht disziplin einfordert wichtig ist
dabei und was wir nie vergessen sollten
die verantwortung gegenüber dem
jeweiligen parteien votum muss zurück
stehen hinter der verantwortung
gegenüber den wählern und der
gesellschaft
ich erinnere an artikel 38 unseres
grundgesetzes daran heißt es die
abgeordneten des deutschen bundestages
den vertreter des ganzen volkes an
aufträge und weisungen nicht gebunden
und nur ihrem gewissen verantwortlich
und ihrem gewissen unterworfen
es bleibt dabei es gibt kein imperatives
mandat
liebe kolleginnen kollegen heute wird
unsere demokratie neu herausgefordert
die gefühlte distanz zwischen bürgern
und politik steigt entscheidungen die im
parlamentarischen und rechtsstaatlichen
verfahren getroffen werden stoßen
mitunter auf unverständnis oder gar auf
protest bürger erwarten politische
führung und reformfähigkeit aber sie
wollen auch demokratische
verständigungen moderation und ausgleich
immer mehr bürger organisieren ihre
interessen und initiativen außerhalb der
klassischen parteipolitischen strukturen
zugleich ziehen sich leider zu viele
menschen ganz aus der politischen
öffentlichkeit zurück in den sozialen
medien werden rassismus antisemitismus
sexismus misstrauen ressentiments und
populistische hetze kultiviert wir
dürfen unsere mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger nicht diesen stimmen und
stimmungen überlassen
es ist wie mehr unsere pflicht das
vertrauen in die wehrhafte engagierte
und lernen eine demokratie zu stärken
durch unser reden und durch unser
handeln
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
können stolz sein auf unsere lebendige
demokratie
in ihr geht es nicht nur darum dass am
ende mehrheiten entscheiden sondern auch
darum dass minderheiten genauso ihre
rechte wahrnehmen können und dass die
menschen erkennen dass im deutschen
bundestag alle überzeugungen zur sprache
gebracht werden können und zwar von
allen bürgern woher sie auch kommen
woran sie glauben welchen geschlechts
sie sind oder welchen bildungsgrad sie
besitzen dabei
dabei ist es die vornehmste aufgabe des
parlaments die freiheits und grundrechte
aller bürger zu wahren und zu sichern
damit die bürger im rahmen dieser
gesetze ihr leben möglichst frei
gestalten können und ihre privatsphäre
geschützt wird
[Musik]
unsere gemeinsame aufgabe muss es sein
dafür zu sorgen die gesellschaftlichen
debatten unserer zeit wieder dahin
zurück zu holen wo sie hingehören
nämlich hier in den deutschen bundestag
genau hier ist der platz der
auseinandersetzung der verschiedenen
politischen ausrichtungen und
überzeugungen hier im deutschen
bundestag sind die parteien in dem maße
vertreten wie sie in freier wahl
bestimmt worden sind deshalb kommen hier
die unterschiedlichen politischen
strömungen zu gelten und zwar zur
geltung und zwar in dem verhältnis wie
sie von den wählern unterstützung
erhalten haben
das zerrbild von der politik wie es
beispielsweise in den sozialen medien
oder in manchen fernsehtalkshows
dargeboten werden gibt diese fähre
repräsentation nicht wieder bei
letzteren bei letzteren werden häufig
vertreter auffälliger positionen
eingeladen weil dies eine höhere
einschaltquote verspricht
was bedeutet das für uns wir müssen den
menschen auf augenhöhe begegnen und ihre
neue ihnen orientierung geben
wir brauchen eine lebendige lebensnahe
debattenkultur
wir müssen dabei eine sprache sprechen
die verstanden wird
wir müssen die unterschiedlichen
positionen klar und deutlich
herausarbeiten damit die wähler sich bei
ihrer wahlentscheidung daran orientieren
können es muss für uns dass latein der
lateinische grundsatz gelten zwar wieder
in modo forderte in re also maßvoll im
ton aber bestimmt in der sache
wie auch bundespräsident frank walter
steinmeier bei seiner rede zur deutschen
einheit sagte kontroversen
aber auch differenzen darf keine
unversöhnlichkeit entstehen
ich kann ihm nur zustimmen wir brauchen
weniger ideologische grabenkämpfe als
problemorientierte lösungen
liebe kolleginnen kollegen zum schluss
möchte ich noch auf die aktuelle größe
des bundestages zu sprechen kommen
wir spüren alle selbst dass der
bundestag mit 709 mitgliedern eine
unerwartet hohe anzahl an abgeordneten
erreicht hat die größe dieses
aufgeblähten parlaments trägt er dazu
bei dass die arbeitsfähigkeit des
bundestages genauso wie sein ansehen bei
den bürgern leidet auch wegen der
dadurch gestiegenen kosten wie der
bisherige bundestagspräsident norbert
lammert riege auch ich an dass sich der
bundestag rasch mit einer reform des
wahlrechts befasst
im interesse der funktionsfähigkeit des
parlaments darf es dabei keine
taktischen machtspiele geben
meiner meinung nach war das alte
wahlrecht im wesentlichen von allen
politischen kräften akzeptiert wenn es
keine schnelle einigung gibt sollte der
bundestag dieses wieder in kraft setzen
notfalls mit verfassungsändernde
mehrheit für die neue legislaturperiode
wünsche ich uns allen das notwendige
verantwortungsgefühl für faire und
sachgerechte auseinandersetzungen mit
klarheit und augenmaß
lassen sie uns den bürgerinnen und
bürgern beweisen dass unsere demokratie
hohe integrationskraft besitzt das wir
nicht sprachlos gegenüber hitze und
parolen sind dass wir emotionen
argumente entgegen setzen und dass wir
ernsthaft lösungen für die probleme der
zukunft finden
ich freue mich auf eine gute
zusammenarbeit
ja soweit die rede von herrn
ein ungewöhnlicher anfang berichteten
doch mit einem vorgestellten auch zdg ja
das war sicherlich ungewöhnlich das war
sie genau geschuldet war der emotion ich
hatte das vorher schon gesagt
trotz war seine rede die doch noch mal
deutlich macht sie hier ist der zentrale
ort der politischen entscheidung er hat
auch gesagt wir wollen hier in diesem
bundestag keine stigmatisieren wir
wollen faire auseinandersetzung aber
jeder muss sich an die spielregeln
halten rechte licht setzt dass die frage
die frage der größe des parlament
angesprochen
fast schon so ein kleines pflichtenheft
aber jetzt sehen wir mal weiter hieß als
alterspräsident